der italienische rocksängerin gianna
vero wird auch als kopf ab arzt rebell
und doktor frankenstein bezeichnet fest
steht er hat einen unvorstellbaren plan
denn er wird tatsächlich der erste sein
der einen menschlichen kopf auf den
körper eines anderen transportiert damit
will cannavaro menschliches leben
verlängern cyborgs erschaffen und lange
weltraummissionen enorm vereinfachen
seine kritiker bezeichnen den plan als
makaber und unethisch doch klar ist auch
es wäre eine unfassbare revolution im
medizinischen bereich wie sein blutiger
plan konkret aussieht welche hürden er
dafür noch zu nehmen hat und ob es
wirklich zu diesem riesigen szenario
kommen wird jetzt in klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen an
dieser stelle einen riesen dank an meine
whatsapp community hier wurde das thema
vorgeschlagen und hier ist es auch schon
wie ihr dabei sein könnt also bei der
community erfahrt ihr am ende des videos
er sorgt immer wieder für schlagzeilen
denn sergio cannavaro ist hartnäckig und
lässt sich auch von den zahlreichen
kritikern und kritikerinnen nicht
beirren sein plan steht fest schon seit
jahren will er der erste sein der eine
kopf transplantation durchführt bei
einem lebenden menschen er beruft sich
dabei auf seine aufgabe als mediziner
menschen zu helfen beispielsweise
patienten die gelähmt sind und im
rollstuhl sitzen doch das spielt wohl
nur eine untergeordnete rolle kam vero
geht es hauptsächlich um eine
technologie die leben verlängert
menschen jünger macht denn ein alter
kopf könnte seiner meinung nach quasi
durch einen jungen körper regeneriert
werden und der italienischen
neurochirurg denkt noch weiter
stichwort cyborgs zum beispiel konkret
meinte damit einen menschlichen kopf auf
einem maschinellen körper war gänsehaut
oder und seine vision betreffen weitere
bereiche er denkt auch an die raumfahrt
und sieht erfolgreiche kopf
transplantation als schlüssel um gegen
die über population der erde durch die
menschen anzukommen in einem interview
mit der österreichischen zeitung kurier
hat cannavaro einmal gesagt dass wir in
der zukunft vor gezwungen sein werden
andere planeten wie den mars zu
besiedeln und auf der langen reise
dorthin wäre ein
kopf transplantation eine gute
möglichkeit das leben der menschen zu
verlängern seine überzeugung ist es auch
dass man dafür auch mal grenzen
überschreiten soll er vergleicht seine
kritiker mit den zweifeln zahlreicher
medizinerinnen und mediziner bevor die
erste herztransplantation weltweit
stattgefunden hat cannavaro sieht sich
selbst in der tradition solcher medizin
pioniere sein projekt heißt helfen 2013
hat er das erste mal der öffentlichkeit
vorgestellt und häfen steht für head an
astro moses venture von head für kopf
affe an astro moses also eine verbindung
von anatomische strukturen und wenn für
venture wagners und sein plan sei
bereits weitgehend fortgeschritten drei
stufen seien dafür notwendig die erste
ist seiner ansicht nach bereits sehr
erfolgreich verlaufen
bei der komplizierten operation wurde
der kopf einer frischen männerleiche auf
den körper einer anderen gesetz beide
körper waren zu forschungszwecken
freigegeben die op dauerte 18 stunden
überhaupt cannavaro verließ sie nach
plan fest steht jedoch auch dass man
hier nicht überprüfen konnte ob die
blutversorgung des gehirns die zeit über
gewährleistet war und das ist ein sehr
entscheidender punkt genau dieser aspekt
soll jetzt in der zweiten stufe geklärt
werden
diese soll an zwei hirntoten spendern
durchgeführt werden deren herz aber noch
schlägt diese aktion steht als nächstes
auf ghana virus agenda doch auch hier
gibt es wie gesagt noch einige dinge zu
klären und auch bei stufe 3 von den
dreien dem großen finale sind noch
fragen offen hauptsächlich im ethischen
bereich denn bislang findet sich kein
land der welt dass es zulässt dass
cannavaro seine ideen in die praxis
umsetzt trotz dieser hürden steht der
ablauf der finalen kopf transplantation
schon sehr konkret fest aber achtung das
ist jetzt echt nichts für schwache
nerven mehr als 100 spezialisten und
spezialistin werden beteiligt sein
den kopf eines körperlich schwer kranken
menschen auf den körper eines hirntoten
spenders zu setzen
spender und empfänger werden zuvor
heruntergekühlt auf etwa 12 grad um die
ihren zellen in eine art standby modus
zu versetzen
denn hier brauchen sie weitaus weniger
sauerstoff als gewöhnlich und können
einige zeit ohne blutzirkulation
auskommen 12 chirurgen werden spender
und
fenger operieren beide werden dazu in
einem metallgestell sitzen dass sie
fixiert ein wirklich großes bild wie
eben schon gesagt ist vor allem die
blutversorgung des gehirns entscheidung
diese zu gewährleisten wird am tag vor
der op einen bypass an der
halsschlagader des empfängers gelegt am
großen tag selbst folgen dann die
freilegung von muskeln sehnen arterien
und so weiter und zwar synchron bei
spender und empfänger körper dann wird
der körper von kopf getrennt und zwar
zwischen dem fünften und dem sechsten
halswirbel und dann bleibt nur sehr
kurze zeit um die oberen teile der
metall gestelle zu tauschen und den kopf
des spenders mit dem körper des
empfängers zu verbinden arterien
luftröhre dann die speiseröhre und die
wirbelsäule doch hier herrscht große
skepsis denn viele experten teams
erscheint es als unlösbare aufgabe das
rückenmark wieder so zu verbinden dass
es auch funktionsfähig ist denn dies
würde ja auch die heilung wieder
querschnittsgelähmte patienten bedeuten
kann avéro argumentiert jedoch dass es
einen unterschied gäbe bei rückenmark
das mit einem sauberen schnitt
durchtrennt wurde sei es möglich die
beschädigten nerven mit bestimmten
stoffen zu versiegeln und dann auch
wieder zu verbinden konkret hat er hier
den wirkstoff träger namens
polyethylenglykol pg im kopf er beruft
sich auf tierversuche in denen
durchtrennt das rückenmark wieder
erfolgreich verbunden werden konnte
andere experten und expertinnen aus dem
medizinischen bereich sehen das äußerst
kritisch und hinterfragen das potenzial
von p&g einige bezeichnen cannavaros
ideen auch als menschen versuche die
ethische standards unterlaufen
der großteil der mediziner und
medizinerin jedenfalls ich sich einig
dass die wissenschaft zum heutigen
zeitpunkt noch nicht so weit sei ja und
der neurochirurg dagegen beruft sich auf
zahlreiche tests ja doch die sagen bei
weitem noch nicht aus oder genug aus um
seine geplante kopf transplantation an
lebenden menschen durchzuführen und
tatsächlich wäre seinen eingriff nur
dann erfolgreich und noch viel mehr
also eine medizinische revolution wenn
der körper dem neuen gehirn gehorcht und
sich bewegen kann obwohl die wirbelsäule
durchtrennt war
doch selbst wenn das tatsächlich klappen
würde ist fraglich was das mit der
psyche
des patienten oder der patientin machen
würden nur als beispiel der patient der
die erste hand transplantation bekam
ließ dass einige zeit später wieder
rückgängig machen er konnte die neue
hand nicht hat seine eigene an agenten
viele transplantierte berichten von
persönlichkeitsveränderungen und es gibt
natürlich viele weitere ethische fragen
kann man teile des körpers wie ein
ersatzteillager behandeln und
austauschen ist der körper nicht mehr
als ein anhängsel des kopfes dennoch
tauchen immer wieder neue schlagzeilen
auf die den termin für das große
ereignis der ersten kopf transplantation
ankündigen im jahr 2016 jesus das
experiment werde ende 2017 stattfinden
dann wurde es verschoben ende 2017 wurde
es dann auf 2018 terminiert es soll an
der haben medical university in china
stattfinden werden ja schon berichtet
dass dort viel mehr möglich ist um den
fortschritt des landes eben deutlich
nach vorne zu treiben doch auch das ist
mittlerweile sehr unsicher denn einige
chinesische behörden haben zweifel
angemeldet dass eine solche kopf
transplantation bei menschen mit
chinesischem recht vereinbar wäre zudem
schlägt sich der italienische
neurochirurg neben den ganzen ethischen
bedenken auch noch mit anderen fragen
herum denn eine wichtige voraussetzung
für seine pläne sind passende kandidaten
oder kandidatinnen er selbst vergleicht
das öfter mal mit der suche nach dem
passenden astronauten für die
mondlandung
denn nicht nur geschlecht hautfarbe und
körpergröße müssen stimmen sondern auch
der immun typ längerer zeit galt der
russe waleri spiridonow als geeigneter
kandidat für das experiment doch
mittlerweile sieht es so aus als könnte
das projekt möglicherweise in china
stattfinden das problem der kopf des
russen würde vom körperbau und der
hautfarbe nicht so der eines chinesen
passen zudem hat sich ist die region
mittlerweile für eine andere op
entschieden ein absolutes thema wenn er
als erstes neues dazu und zu allen
anderen themen erfahren wollt dann
meldet euch hierbei whatsapp andern
erfahrt ihr vor allen anderen vom
neuesten video garantiert ihr könnt dort
direkt in der redaktion von klicks um
mitmachen und themen vorschlagen oder
fragen zu videos stellen
der direkte draht zu mir einfach eben
hier draufklicken und natürlich nicht
das abo mit gloco zu weiter vergessen
hier geht es weiter mit dafür
draufklicken mensch wird
zur schimäre mit schweine organ
ansonsten wenn ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran